(jazz house band)
(audience cheers)
- Oh my goodness.
- Hello!
- What a beautiful studio!
- I know, we're excited.
Thank you.
- They told me they didn't
have money for nice studios.
- (laughs) I love being
in this building with you.
You are.
- It's a great building.
- I have to say this, you
were the very first person
when we announced that we
were coming to New York,
he sent me a, like, handwritten card.
Like.
- Yeah.
- Saying, "Welcome to 30 Rock.
I'll show you around the commissary."
Which, by the way, has really good food.
- It's a excellent commissary!
- Yes.
- That was the first thing
I was gonna tell you.
- It's, like, when you said it in a card,
and you brought up food, I was like,
"I don't know."
- Yeah.
- 'Cause, like, a cafeteria
can, it can be suspect.
- It could be. I started here in 2001,
and the cafeteria in 2001 was a dump.
- Okay, okay. I came at the right time.
- And, they rebuilt the commissary.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, I take it to the streets.
I brag about it everywhere.
- Oh my God.
It's so good, yeah.
Yeah.
- Yeah. It's really great.
- I love the banana smoothie.
- You do have to pay for the food.
I've heard about you at previous places,
that you, there's an assumption
because you're Kelly Clarkson,
you can just take the food
and walk right out.
- Yes.
- But, I do need you to stop.
- Well, I'm here now, 30 Rock,
so, I'm just. I want free food.
(both laugh)